bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regardez l'émission spéciale 8 mars ce
soir avec les brunes Pivet bonsoir et
merci bonsoir votre grand témoin
première femme au perchoir dans notre
histoire dans le grand bain chaud
bouillant des retraites on va parler de
tout cela on va revenir sur le climat
dans l'hémicycle et la manière avec
laquelle vous présidez l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un travail
d'équilibriste on le verra mais on
commence avec la femme de pouvoir que
vous êtes le pouvoir des femmes n'est
plus à démontrer et pourtant elles sont
encore peu nombreuses à occuper les
postes clés alors les femmes de pouvoir
sont elles des hommes comme les autres y
a-t-il une manière féminine de diriger
nous en avons réuni quatre autour de
vous il y a une brune TV je vous
présente mes invités dans un instant
c'est notre grand débat ce soir avant de
retrouver à 20h15 nos affranchis deux
parties pris pour vous interpeller il y
a les brunes Pivet c'est parti ça vous
regarde spécial 8 mars on y va
[Musique]
madame la Présidente cette expression
n'est plus si rare aujourd'hui et
pourtant quelque chose est encore
compliqué
contrarié empêcher quatre femmes autour
de vous ce soir il y a le brune Pivet
pour débattre de la place des femmes
dans les postes à haute responsabilité
bonsoir Valérie rabots bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale député socialiste
du Tarn-et-Garonne première femme à
avoir présidé un groupe politique à
l'Assemblée nationale première femme à
avoir été rapporteur du budget et
c'était il y a pas si longtemps vous
êtes aussi passé par l'entreprise on va
en parler vous avez été membre du comité
exécutif d'une filiale de la banque BNP
Paribas bonsoir Mayada boulots bonsoir
ravi de vous accueillir vous êtes
présidente exécutive davas Paris qui
fait partie World Wild c'est le premier
groupe de communication dans le monde
vous avez fait votre carrière dans la
communication politique vous avez piloté
la communication de Jean Castex à
Matignon vous retrouvez le groupe avast
aujourd'hui et quelle place on va en
parler le fait d'être une femme
d'ailleurs je crois que ça vous a aidé
et vous l'assumez complètement bonsoir
Gwena la jolie Coz bienvenue première
présidente de la cour d'appel de
Poitiers vous venez de publier femme de
justice chez Eric Enrique B édition
c'est un livre dans lequel vous dressez
des portraits de femmes magistrates et
on va le voir avec vous il y a un énorme
plafond de verre dans la magistrature
quand il s'agit d'atteindre le haut de
la hiérarchie judiciaire vous nous allez
vous expliquer tout ça enfin bonsoir
l'orage au bar première femme à la tête
de l'École polytechnique dont vous êtes
la nouvelle directrice nommée en octobre
2022 il était temps j'ai envie de dire
parce que l'École polytechnique est la
228 ans vous êtes vous-même
polytechnicienne promotion 99 et vous
êtes ingénieur général de l'armement
voilà pour la présentation des femmes
sur ce plateau mais un homme pour les
présenter je vais donner la parole tout
de suite à Stéphane blackovski pour un
billet particulier spécial 8 mars le
chrono de Blacko tout de suite
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir ces femmes bonsoir
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à toutes et à
toutes en fait alors à vous de jouer
j'ai remarqué vous l'avez sans trop
marqué que ce soir on a quasiment que
des présidents dans le studio quand vous
avez fait la présentation la présidente
de l'Assemblée bien sûr avec la vie
présidente une des vices présidente de
l'Assemblée mais présidente quand même
Gwena Julie cause elle aussi elle est
présidente et même mieux que ça les
premières présidentes de la cour d'appel
de Poitiers donc là ça nous fait déjà
trois présidentes et c'est là que les
fans de question pour un champion vont
être content parce que quatre à la suite
avec Mayada boulot ce qui elle aussi est
président ou l'avait dit de Avast Paris
donc une boîte de com qui souffle à
l'oreille des politiques bon évidemment
je suis un petit peu gêné pour vous
Madame shobard vous n'êtes que
directrice générale de l'École
polytechnique bon je vous félicite c'est
la première fois qu'une femme est nommée
à ce poste mais manifestement
apolitechnique c'est un peu comme en
France le président est et reste un
homme parce que là nous sommes donc le 8
mars 2023 il doit être quoi à peu près
19h45 et alors où je parle aucune femme
n'a jamais été élu présidente de la
République en France pourtant ça fait
quand même 50 ans que des femmes se
présentent la première fois c'était
presque 50 ans en 74 c'était une
travailleuse c'était une révolutionnaire
et c'était une femme on l'écoute
et bien oui je suis une femme et j'ose
me présenter comme candidate à la
présidence de cette république Dom c'est
légal et pourtant cela choque cela
paraît étrange même aux hommes de gauche
et cela doit l'être puisque je suis la
seule sur plusieurs centaines de
ministres qui se sont succédés depuis 30
ans seulement deux femmes huit femmes
aujourd'hui au Parlement sur 49 députés
bon les choses ont quand même un peu
évolué je vous montre l'évolution de la
proportion de femmes à l'Assemblée on
notera quand même que c'est la dernière
législature ça a un petit peu baissé
mais on a une présidente de l'Assemblée
qui est une femme mais mais toujours pas
de président de la République qui soit
une femme pourtant moi je peux assez
optimiste je pense que la première femme
n'a pas encore française n'a pas encore
été élu Présidente je pense qu'elle est
déjanée elle est quelque part en France
là elle va occuper son poste elle est
peut-être même dans ce studio vous allez
me dire oh non moi ça ne m'intéresse pas
de Emmanuel Macron et ça c'est très bon
signe parce que c'est exactement ce que
Edouard Philippe vous voyez vous êtes
sur le bon le bon démarrage non mais
franchement madame ne dis pas que la
politique ne vous intéresse pas Madame
Chauvard vous avez été dans des cabinets
conseillères et puis franchement n'ayez
aucun complexe ça serait pas la première
fois qu'un élève de Polytechnique serait
élu à l'Élysée je vous rappelle regardez
si vous ne le reconnaissez pas à cause
de ses cheveux je vous donne un indice
ça commence par Giscard ça finit par
destin madame Julie cause mais
franchement vous avez le profil aussi
vous êtes brillante peut-être même
brillante ici puisque à 22 ans vous
étiez la plus jeune magistrate en France
vous avez le goût de la politique vous
avez été dans des directrices de cabinet
dans le gouvernement Hollande puis
surtout même dans votre métier de
magistrat tout le monde trouve que vous
avez tellement œuvré pour l'égalité
femme homme que regarder ce que dit la
presse elle dit mais non cette femme
elle est ministre on vous voit très bien
ministre de la Justice donc franchement
pourquoi pas présidente mais il y a des
boulots elle a aussi des atouts bah oui
conseillère politique un coup chez
Marisol Touraine on est chez holl un
coup à maquignon avec Castex donc ça
fait très bon pour une présidente de se
rendre avec la droite de s'entendre avec
la gauche et puis surtout vous savez
qu'en France l'animateur préféré des
Français que vous allez reconnaître
évidemment un père égyptien donc
pourquoi les Français ne voteraient pas
pour une présidente qui elle aussi un
père Égypte cochets
vous êtes une pionnière dans tous les
domaines première femme rapporteur
première femme président mais surtout
vous avez incontestablement les
capacités pour diriger ce pays enfin
c'était marqué dans le journal je
voulais pas inventé président Macron
vous a proposé le poste à Matignon c'est
vous qui avez refusé de bornes est un
deuxième choix donc si on peut être
installé à maintenir on peut
parfaitement diriger la France alors
j'ai pas beaucoup parlé de vous madame
la Présidente mais bon c'est normal les
téléspectateurs vous connaissent un peu
plus si j'ai juste quelques secondes
pour vous poser une question maintenant
que vous avez présidé les représentants
des Français ce que ça vous dirait pas
de présider mais directement en fait les
Français
allez une petite réponse
je me dis souvent que j'ai deux
circonscriptions la mienne dans les
Yvelines et puis l'autre que c'est la
France entière et la fonction que
j'exerce aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée est
une fonction absolument incroyable et la
présence mais en fait c'est pas le sujet
c'est pas le moment et ça n'est pas la
question moi je fais toujours vous savez
je mets toujours un pied devant l'autre
et aujourd'hui j'ai eu l'immense honneur
je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte à quel point pour moi c'est
quelque chose d'important et c'est
quelque chose dans lequel je vais mettre
toute mon énergie matin midi et soir et
je ne pense qu'à ça donc ce qui vous
prête les intentions sont pas forcément
d'ailleurs peut-être vos alliés on ne
sait pas bien ça pose la question de
l'ambition mesdames vous êtes des femmes
d'ambition je pense pas que ce soit un
gros mot pour aucune de vos quatre et
pourtant on peut avoir des grandes
carrières et être un peu freiné quand on
est une femme est-ce que est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire très franchement si
être une femme aujourd'hui pour vous ça
a été un accélérateur au contraire ça
vous a ralenti elle est rabot
alors c'est une question qui est
difficile
moi je pense qu'il y a des difficultés
mais je pense pas que ça ralentisse
alors c'est peut-être un peu
contradictoire ce que je dis je prends
des exemples on parlait que ma voisine
quand j'étais en classe prépa sur mes
copies j'avais ah bah tiens rabot tu as
su faire ça jamais aucun professeur
n'aurait écrit ça sur une copie d'un
garçon jamais et ça si vous avez la
niaque ça vous donne l'énergie en disant
lui je lui en mettre plein la figure et
ben quand on a cette énergie là
intérieur ça vous force à avancer mais
ça peut fonctionner de manière
individuelle parce que chacun a son
caractère ou chacune à son caractère ça
peut pas fonctionner quand on pense tout
un pays entier et toute une avancée pour
une société et c'est à dire et c'est là
où le pouvoir politique doit intervenir
pour faire tomber les blocages
donc j'ai pas de réponse peut-être très
sexy mais c'est à vous donner mais voilà
quand on vous met des obstacles vous
allez en dire lui je lui en montrais et
puis ça va coller il y a des inégalités
qui donnent la niaque et qui font
avancer Gwenola Joly causes avoir été
une femme dans la magistrature c'est un
plus ou ça peut être compliqué moi je
dirais que la question se pose en deux
temps c'est à dire que passer le
concours de l'École nationale de la
magistrature ça il y a aucune difficulté
les jeunes filles s'y prêtent volontiers
elles vont même y consacrer plusieurs
années de leur vie et elles vont réussir
ce très difficile concours donc rentrer
dans la magistrature c'est pas un
problème ce qui est plus compliqué
ensuite c'est d'y faire un parcours de
pouvoir y prendre des responsabilités et
là pour le coup être une femme n'est pas
un avantage mais un avantage pour des
raisons comme vous venez de l'indiquer
non pas individuel mais systémique ce
sont c'est le plafond de verre qui se
met en place dans la magistrature à
cause de règles vous savez les règles
dont on dit qu'elles sont neutres et
qu'en réalité elles sont masculines et
les femmes et les hommes ne vont pas
répondre de la même façon à ses règles
j'en pense je pense à une
particulièrement qui est très très forte
chez nous c'est la question de la
mobilité géographique et ça la mobilité
géographique la magistrature on change
régulièrement c'est un peu comme la
diplomatie sauf qu'on reste le plus
souvent en métropole tout le temps tout
le temps de manière quasi obsessionnelle
la magistrature française veut que les
magistrats changent de territoire on va
irrégulièrement dans le détail vous j'ai
cru comprendre j'ai cru lire que au fond
vous saviez que vous étiez aujourd'hui
présidente exécutive parce que vous êtes
une femme en tout cas pas uniquement
pour ça mais ça comptait ça a été un
plus ça a été bien sûr alors après à
notre arrivée là j'ai quand même eu un
parcours en cabinet ministériel et en
réalité je ne suis pas certaine d'avoir
jamais été confronté à une
discrimination ou même un désavantage du
fait d'être une femme même si c'est
arrivé à un moment où j'avais des
enfants et je commençais à en avoir et
en réalité on se serait bien que la
maternité continue quand même à être un
obstacle davantage pour les femmes que
pour les hommes parce que il faut
rentrer pour les enfants etc or c'est
des vies ou le rythme est extrêmement
intense il y a pas de week-end où les
soirées sont extrêmement remplies par le
travail etc etc donc c'était peut-être
plutôt ça
on va dire un obstacle indirect en fait
pour une femme ensuite dans le privé et
en particulier à la tête d'une agence de
communication alors ce sont des métiers
qui sont extrêmement féminisés à tous
les niveaux donc il y a pas de
discrimination systémique comme le
disait Gwénola néanmoins aujourd'hui
c'est sûr il y a un moment femme il y a
eu énormément de d'affaires de qui sont
remontés sur les inégalités les
injustices les discriminations le
sexisme etc dans différentes boîtes dans
le privé et je pense que d'une certaine
manière oui ça avantagé les femmes enfin
cela dit moi je l'assume complètement si
ça a pu jouer si c'est pas l'unique
raison j'assume complètement l'oracle au
bar le moment femme aussi vous en avez
bénéficié je suis une femme scientifique
et je suis une femme militaire donc par
ses choix que j'ai fait par goût par
envie je me suis retrouvée à évoluer
dans des milieux extrêmement masculins
ou les femmes sont rares et donc ce que
j'ai observé c'est que les femmes sont
plus
identifiées quand il y a 100 hommes et
des femmes tout le monde connaît le nom
le prénom et le visage des 10 donc elles
sont plus identifiées plus observées
plus exposées aussi si le regard qu'on
leur porte est bienveillant ça peut être
porteur et je pense que ça a été mon cas
en revanche ce n'est pas le ressenti est
vécu de toutes les femmes qui évoluent
dans dans ces milieux très masculins
donc ça peut être un peu l'exception qui
confirme la règle de l'absence des
femmes et elles vont arriver c'est pas
un secret vous avez une carrière d'abord
assez disparate hétéroclite vous avez
fait plein de choses très différentes il
y a eu un moment dans votre vie vous
avez un peu suspendu mais entre
parenthèses votre carrière vous allez
suivre votre mari à l'étranger
et donc vous avez peut-être accepté de
vous mettre un peu entre parenthèses
d'aller vous occuper de vos enfants avec
lui est-ce que c'est bien vécu ça est-ce
que vous l'assumer
alors je partage pas les termes de votre
question avoir suivi son mari avoir mis
des questions oui entre parenthèses mais
c'est pas ça c'est pas comme ça que moi
je l'ai ressenti on a fait un choix de
vie donc un choix de vie de couple un
choix de vie de famille de partir
habiter à l'étranger et nous avons pris
du temps pour constituer une famille
nombreuse dont on avait envie tous les
deux et donc le fait d'avoir eu cette
aventure à l'étranger nous a permis
d'une part de vivre des choses
absolument extraordinaires et de nous
décentrer de ce que pouvait être la
France et ça et la vision qu'on a quand
on est en France et qu'on reste en
France donc ça ça a été très intéressant
et ça m'a permis d'avoir 5 enfants et
c'est ce qui pour moi a été fondamental
parce que moi je crois que aujourd'hui
est venu le moment où on réussit en tant
que femme sans rien abdiquer de ce qui
fait qu'on est une femme et donc on peut
avoir une famille avoir le faire le
choix si on peut le faire de s'arrêter
un temps pour prendre du temps avec ses
enfants changer de carrière aussi si on
a envie et se reformer au milieu de la
vie s'engager dans le monde associatif
s'engager dans le monde politique en
fait il faut en tout cas moi c'est ça
choisir et pas subir
oser ça ne veut pas dire que c'est
facile et je sais que pour plein de
femmes elles n'ont pas cette capacité de
choix et nous notre rôle aujourd'hui en
tant que femme politique c'est de leur
offrir cette capacité de choix leur
permettre de pouvoir s'accomplir sans
qu'il y ait ce jugement de la société
qui fait qu'une femme doit évoluer comme
si ou comme ça alors on va entrer dans
le détail dans vos domaines respectifs
politiques entreprises justice et
métiers scientifiques où sont les
patronnes aujourd'hui tour d'horizon
signé Thibault innoc
première femme élue à la tête de
l'Assemblée nationale Yaël brande Pivet
votre ascension au perchoir était le
signe que la bataille est gagnée pour
les femmes en politique pas vraiment
avec 37% de femmes députés c'est
assemblée étant léger recul sur la
précédente les postes à responsabilités
ils sont en revanche pour la première
fois également répartis avec notamment 5
vice-présidentes un constat loin d'être
vrai au niveau local 45% de femmes
conseillères municipales mais seulement
20% de mer 49% de conseillers régional
mais seulement une présidente de région
sur 5 la parité en politique consiste
encore souvent pour les hommes à ne
céder leur place aux femmes qu'au poste
les moins importants un constat qui
établit une équation valable dans
quasiment tous les secteurs plus on
monte dans la hiérarchie plus la place
des femmes sera récit illustration dans
la justice 69% de femmes dans la
magistrature mais seulement 16% au plus
haut poste de l'institution 70%
d'avocats mais une sur cinq seulement
associer de son cabinet et du côté des
entreprises alors depuis 2011 la loi
prévoit 40% de femmes au minimum dans
les conseils d'administration objectif
atteint avec 46% aujourd'hui mais en ce
qui concerne les comités de direction
c'est autre chose seulement 25% de
femmes exerce des fonctions dirigeantes
dans les grandes entreprises des
inégalités qui se retrouvent encore trop
souvent à la racine ainsi certaines
filières restent l'apanage des hommes en
école d'ingénieurs on ne compte que 33%
de femmes dans la plus prestigieuse
d'entre elles l'École polytechnique
elles ne sont que 17%
[Musique]
17% 20% allez trop de pause
vous diriez déjà pour commencer on va
parler de la politique et puis on va
dispatcher ensuite que on progresse ça
va mieux on n'est pas à la parité
parfaite à l'Assemblée nationale on voit
que au niveau local encore un gros
effort à faire il y a peu de femmes
notamment dans les conseils régionaux
dans les mairies mais est-ce qu'on
avance où est-ce que c'est toujours le
bon vieux machos sexiste à l'Assemblée
moi j'ai un peu l'impression que alors
non mais laisse tomber 37% de femmes une
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est pas forcément l'endroit qui est le
plus macho les chiffres que vous venez
de montrer sont assez éloquents parce
que effectivement il y a quasiment la
moitié de conseillère municipal il y a
que 20% de mer bon je crois qu'il y a
quand même sur le pouvoir en tout cas le
pouvoir politique il y a une seule règle
le pouvoir ne se donne pas il se prend
je pense que il y a le bon Pivet
elle a été confrontée à il y avait des
candidats masculins moi vous avez dit
que j'avais été première présidente d'un
groupe il y avait deux autres candidats
masculins face à moi donc à chaque fois
l'élection on se les gagner
c'est le pouvoir en politique alors je
parle pas de d'autres domaines il se
prend et il y a pas d'autres règles et
ça les femmes en politique donc toute
contenue Valérie a complètement raison
et c'est vos chiffres l'illustre très
bien on a fait des lois pour promouvoir
la parité en politique et aujourd'hui
les conseils municipaux les conseils
départementaux les conseils régionaux
sont paritaires pour autant la tête de
liste ne l'est pas et donc en fait il
faut que les femmes acceptent sur une
municipalité de prendre la tête et de ne
pas être la numéro 2 mais de dire moi je
vais mener la liste sur le Conseil
départemental c'est pareil on a besoin
de femmes en politique qui
osent qui acceptent d'être numéro 1
et qui accepte de prendre des
responsabilités
il faut être élu et donc prendre le
pouvoir il y a les postes et les mandats
mais il y a le climat alors vous il y a
une bonne Pivet vous dites ça dans
l'hémicycle quand on dit attention
sexisme du côté de Sandrine Rousseau
voilà ce que vous répondez
il a une admissible en particulier pour
ma collègue mais pour toutes les
collègues femmes que dès lors qu'il y a
une prise de parole comme celle-ci il y
a des exclamations comme ça dans
l'hémicycle
franchement mais franchement on est dans
un hémicycle pour la première fois cette
assemblée présidée par une femme j'ai
cinq vice-présidentes à mes côtés j'ai
une première question j'ai quatre
présidents de groupe
mais arrêtez
vous étiez pas sexy
allez-y alors madame la Présidente se
rappelle au règlement au titre de
l'article 100 sur la bonne tenue de
débats je rappelle parce que finalement
vous avez un peu les mêmes arguments que
le RN c'est assez pas parce qu'il y a
une femme qui s'en sorte que toutes les
femmes s'en sortent
alors dans ce déballage vous qui
regardez c'est intéressant le regard de
la communication on a fait des progrès
il faut arrêter avec le sexisme ou au
contraire il y a le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité qui dit le sexisme il est là
il est bien là il y a même un back clash
un retour de bâton conservateur et
réactionnel non c'est sûr qu'il y a des
progrès je veux dire on le constat
toutes les différences de salaires les
promotions de femmes quand elles
reviennent de congé maternité
légale meilleur accès en tout cas des
postes de responsabilité évidemment ne
serait-ce que parce que les générations
qui arrivent aujourd'hui à l'âge adulte
ou au pouvoir on grandit dans des
familles un peu différentes parfois
recomposées mais souvent avec des
familles monoparentales ou la mère
travaillait était plus indépendante etc
par contre 1 évidemment des différences
subsistes et on voit bien sur plein de
droits ne serait-ce que le droit à
l'avortement par exemple sur lequel on a
beaucoup parlé ces dernières ces
derniers mois et ces dernières semaines
il y a des reculs possibles donc non il
faut jamais lâcher la pression et mais
quand vous entendez dire ça va en fait
il y a déjà quatre non vice-présidentes
à l'Assemblée sur le sur le climat sur
le sexisme peut-être je vous laisse
répondre et puis vous est-ce que ces
mots là ils sont particuliers vous dites
à Sandrine Rousseau ça suffit en fait
arrêtez de d'attaquer sur le sexisme
vous vous méprenez sur la réalité mais
parce que c'est ma conviction profonde
aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle nous n'avons pas un
hémicycle ou s'exprime matin midi et
soir le sexisme à l'égard des femmes
politiques je pense que nous avons
franchi un cap parce que le nombre de
députés 37% parce que l'exercice des
responsabilités par des femmes après moi
ce qui m'agace en fait prodigieusement
c'est que une femme considère
des métiers de la communication de la
publicité etc joue beaucoup là-dessus
l'imaginaire dans l'imaginaire la
neutralité et encore masculine on le
voit dans la langue on le voit dans le
droit et on le voit dans la vie
quotidienne même dans des petits détails
enfin je vous donne un petit par exemple
la question des 19 degrés sur le réglage
de du chauffage etc pas mal d'études
montrent qu'il y a une différence de
métabolisme entre les hommes et les
femmes et on voit bien que cette
température là et par défaut celle qui a
été fixée par quel correspond en fait à
un métabolisme masculin c'est un détail
mais au fond ça veut dire quand même
quelque chose je la prends on est encore
dans un moment où la neutralité est
masculine Gwénola jolie cause vous ce
débat sur la question de
l'essentialisation on dit beaucoup
est-ce que il y a une manière féminine
de chez fait qu'est-ce qu'une bonne
chèvre quand on est une femme est-ce que
c'est être un homme comme les autres il
vous agace alors effectivement je suis
très attentive au piège de
l'essentialisation c'est à dire que dire
que nous avons des qualités féminines de
l'autre côté des qualités masculines je
pense que c'est un risque parce que
c'est le risque de dire que par exemple
dans la justice les femmes seraient
d'excellentes juges des enfants et que
les hommes seraient d'excellents
procureurs de la République alors je
suis tout à fait contre cette approche
et chez nous en fait ce qui se joue
c'est vraiment un effet ciseau très fort
entre la mixité et la parité ce que vous
le savez maintenant dans l'imaginaire
les femmes sont juges un 71% aujourd'hui
de la justice est rendue par des femmes
alors effectivement on a l'impression
qu'en fait tout est joué voilà il y a
des femmes partout dans dans la justice
et puis comme par hasard mais ça on
connaît bien ce phénomène en fait c'est
une dissolution des femmes dans la
hiérarchie c'est-à-dire que plus on
monte dans les postes moins il y a de
femmes mais c'est quasiment caricatural
chez nous puisque aujourd'hui une petite
infographie on a pris voilà vraiment le
top du top de la hiérarchie judiciaire
on commence avec le Conseil
constitutionnel Laurent Fabius Didier
Roland tabuto pour le vice-président du
Conseil d'État premier président de la
Cour de cassation Christophe Soula
premier président de la cour d'appel de
Paris Jacques Boulard on aurait pu
rajouter d'ailleurs le procureur de la
République de aujourd'hui le président
comment c'est possible le président du
tribunal de Bobigny vous auriez pu en
rajouter des dizaines et des dizaines
car aujourd'hui nous ne prennent pas le
pouvoir dans la justice alors je suis
assez d'accord avec l'idée qu'il faut le
prendre le pouvoir chez nous ça n'est
pas prendre le pouvoir chez nous c'est
candidater pour le sphère politique
puisque elle a ses règles aussi et c'est
vrai qu'il faut que les femmes
candidates et très souvent le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature dit si les
femmes ne sont pas nommées en
responsabilité dans la magistrature
c'est parce qu'elle ne candidate pas
alors moi je me méfie de cet argument
parce que c'est un peu un argument qui
consiste à remettre le caillou dans le
jardin des femmes c'est de votre faute
quelque part si vous ne réussissez pas à
prendre les postes moi je pense que les
explications sont plus systémiques si
les femmes ne candidatent pas c'est
parce que l'univers globalement ne leur
est pas favorable et qu'elles
comprennent assez rapidement que les
règles du jeu qui ont été fixées par les
hommes comme la température
j'ai peur de pas y arriver quels sont
les arguments peut-être construits
qu'elle se raconte alors de manière
assez classique et comme les femmes dans
tous les domaines je pense elle commence
par me dire semaines qu'elles ont réussi
ce grand et difficile concours de
l'École nationale de la magistrature
qu'elles ne seront pas capables d'être
chef de fe bien entendu alors pourquoi
considère qu'elle considère-t-elle
qu'elle n'en serait pas capable d'abord
elle pense toujours qu'elles ne sont pas
assez formées elles ont toujours
l'impression qu'elles n'ont pas le
niveau pour faire les choses vous
connaissez les hommes candidates avec
80% des compétences et les femmes avec
120 non alors ça ça fonctionne très bien
il y a aussi la peur de prendre la
parole en public ce qui peut sembler
étonnant pour des magistrates qui
préside des audiences toute la journée
pourtant dès lors qu'il faudra prendre
la parole pour défendre une idée ou pour
représenter l'institution de manière
publique elles y sont très réticentes et
puis globalement je les dis tout à
l'heure elles sentent bien que le
système ne l'aurait pas favorable et que
notamment la question de la mobilité
géographique incessante ne va pas être
compatible avec une vie de famille un
équilibre personnel et donc elles vont y
renoncer là où les hommes vont y
répondre autrement ils vont y répondre
ou en tout cas une questionnement sur la
légitimité l'orage au bal alors là on
est dans l'univers masculin par
excellence déjà comment vous vous
expliquez qu'il a fallu pendant si
longtemps pour avoir une directrice ça
peut être technique c'est quand même ça
arrive un peu tard non déjà je voudrais
corriger
un fait il y a eu une présidente du
conseil d'administration de l'école
politique Marion Guilloux il y a déjà
plus d'une dizaine d'années l'école
pretting c'est ouverte aux femmes il y a
pile 50 ans on a célébré le
cinquantenaire de l'ouverture aux femmes
de l'École polytechnique c'est un poste
qui est statutairement réservé un
général de l'armée française s'explique
cela ceci explique en partie cela
et voilà et il était temps que ça arrive
effectivement
dans les milieux scientifiques les 20%
vous voulez les ramener à combien votre
objectif appelé technique c'est quoi
notre vie à 50% c'est déjà 30% en 2026
mais dans ces filières scientifiques à
dominantes mathématique parce qu'on dit
que les femmes ne font pas de science
c'est pas vrai elles font massivement de
la biologie elles vont massivement en
études de médecine et dans les sciences
à dominantes mathématiques et numérique
on n'est pas confronté à un plafond de
verre on est confronté à un plancher de
verre c'est à dire que les femmes ne
s'orientent pas vers ces filières
aujourd'hui il y a 20% de candidates au
concours de l'école politique 20%
d'admises ah oui donc le concours en
lui-même elle le réussit tout aussi bien
que les gars c'est important en revanche
on a un vivier de candidates qui est
notoirement insuffisant alors même que
les filles au lycée sont tout aussi
douées en maths que les garçons les
mêmes raisons dépréciations de soi je ne
vais pas y arriver alors oui il y a le
même phénomène quand elles doivent auto
évaluer leurs compétences en sciences
elles se sous-évalue systématiquement et
donc
je discutais avec des lycéens ce matin
puisqu'on organisait une journée
spéciale fille maths et informatique une
équation lumineuse à Polytechnique et
toute m'ont dit mais oui moi j'ai envie
de faire de la cosmétique de l'énergie
de la santé vous avez envie d'être
ingénieur c'est merveilleux quand je dis
mais est-ce que vous allez vous inscrire
en classe préparatoire
là elle me disent j'ai peur de que ce
soit trop dur j'ai peur de ne pas être
capable de travailler et de travailler à
fond pendant deux ans j'ai peur de la
compétition interne peur de la
compétition Valérie rabot alors vous
c'est particulier parce que vous avez
fait l'épouse des chaussées c'est
ingénieurs grands concours vous étiez à
louer le grand d'ailleurs avec Karine
berger et Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet
voilà je le précise parce que c'est
intéressant après de regarder un peu les
itinéraires quelle réflexions vous allez
moi pour une journée du 8 mars il y a
deux ans une Rencontre avec des jeunes
filles en classe préparatoire
scientifique et j'y suis allée avec
l'inspecteur académique de mon
département et j'étais horrifiée de ce
qu'elles nous ont dit c'est à dire
qu'elles ont été découragées on leur a
dit tu vas voir c'est dur c'est pas fait
pour les filles c'est un milieu très
masculin ce qui est vrai parce qu'on est
que 20% dans une un autre époque 10%
mais 20% c'est pas beaucoup non plus et
bien le système les a découragés que un
système dise à des jeunes filles c'est
pas pour toi tu vas pas y arriver et que
le système encourage les gars le système
c'est quoi le système c'est les
orientations qu'on peut leur donner au
lycée c'est ce qu'elles entendent dans
l'éducation nationale dans l'éducation
nationale et c'est pour ça que je
précise bien que l'inspecteur d'académie
était là parce que il est lui aussi
tombé de sa chaise quand il a entendu
des paroles libres et ces jeunes filles
elles étaient sept sur 70 une classe de
maths sup a une classe de maths spé donc
elles sont très courageuses parce que
quand même 770 c'est pas beaucoup donc à
minima que le système les encourage
d'accord avec ça le système montre pas
que la répartition genre et des rôles
sociaux est en pleine évolution
contrairement à ce qu'on aurait pu
penser on pensait que ça allait être
mieux et en réalité les 15 dernières
années nous montrent qu'il y a une
répartition très forte et très jaurée
des relations
et puis et puis des maths
quand il a fallu choisir les options sur
la réforme du lycée avant il y avait 200
000 lycéens qui faisaient plus de 6
heures de maths par semaine donc 96.000
filles aujourd'hui on est tombé à 100
000 dont 33000 filles divisé par 3 pour
les filles
c'est déflagrateur alors la question
c'est comment on change le système
est-ce qu'on s'agit de changer des
mentalités et là on se divise ça prend
du temps ou est-ce qu'il s'agit de
politique publique leur acheba alors
sans doute un peu des deux il y a des
choses qui prennent du temps vous
parliez des métiers de la tech et du
numérique il faut se rappeler que
l'informatique a été marquée comme la
voiture comme un instrument de puissance
masculine et notamment le PC le c'est le
moment où les femmes ont fui
l'informatique ça prend du temps pour se
remettre de ces de ces imaginaires
construit autour du numérique et de
l'informatique et ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas livrer dès maintenant et
ensuite en termes de politique publique
mettez le doigt sur quelque chose
l'image des classes prépa et les
messages qu'on envoie aux jeunes femmes
qui tentent l'aventure d'une des études
scientifiques
doivent être infléchis aujourd'hui parce
qu'on va dire à un garçon qui sera en
difficulté en classe prépa comme la
plupart des élèves on a été accroche toi
ça va aller on va dire à une fille
et de manière bienveillante ce soit ses
parents ses profs si c'est trop
difficile fais attention à toi ça c'est
ça prend du temps de changer les
mentalités mais c'est aussi votre rôle
Mayada boulot sont dans la communication
la production de discours la publicité
l'effet des slogans des messages l'effet
des slogans le fait des images fait de
façonner les imaginaires jusqu'en même
sur la question scientifique ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on est un moment
encore plus important aujourd'hui pour
la féminisation de ces métiers et
notamment dans la tech puisque arrive
aussi la généralisation de l'utilisation
des outils tels que chat GPT enfin de
l'intelligence artificielle de manière
générale y compris dans nos métiers dans
les métiers de la publicité et
d'ailleurs l'association jamais sans
elle a lancé ce matin une campagne où on
voit que des créatifs ont travaillé sur
le fait l'équivalent de chat GPT pour
les illustrations quand on lui demande
imagine un SIO on a que des figures
masculines imagines une secrétaire enfin
en Anglais le terme n'est pas genre et
on a évidemment que des femmes avec des
petites lunettes des petites jupes etc
etc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire alors
c'est normal puisque c'est ces outils ne
font que un agrégat en fait de ce qui
existe actuellement et donc le
reproduise encore et encore par ailleurs
juste quand même une autre réflexion sur
ce que vous disiez sur la féminisation
des métiers etc on voit bien qu'il y a
évidemment les maths ou les femmes sont
moins présentes qui sont très valorisées
mais à contrario on a aussi un problème
notamment en France sur la valorisation
des métiers dit du Caire des métiers de
l'attention on l'a vu en soi il y a
après la pandémie tous les métiers de
soins en fait
des infirmières qui sont en majorité des
femmes encore là on parle de
valorisation salariale et de la relation
sont des métiers qui sont encore
aujourd'hui très dévalles dévalorisés
pourquoi parce qu'on les lie à travers
une grille de lecture masculine celle du
pouvoir etc etc donc qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire alors il y a évidemment la
question de la norme à travers le
pouvoir politique mais je crois que les
chefs d'entreprise ont aussi un rôle à
jouer alors justement on va y venir à
l'entreprise
encore très très peu de femmes au CAC 40
on sait toujours les mêmes c'est simple
engie McGregor et puis qui d'autre
m'échappe il y a également Sophie Bello
à la tête absolument absolument il y a
eu cet index qui a été mis en place il y
a des progrès avec la loi Zimmermann
Copé mais l'égalité salariale ça marche
pas encore complètement et on voit bien
que ça n'a pas ruisselé des conseils
d'administration on n'a pas beaucoup
plus de femmes dans les dans les
instances dirigeantes dans les comités
exécutifs on a beaucoup progressé on a
beaucoup progressé et c'est comme en
politique on a progressé parce qu'il on
a mis des lois on a fait des lois avec
des quotas on a fixé des objectifs on a
fixé un cadre on a fixé une contrainte
et ça ça marche donc certains disent on
en a pas besoin c'est pas vrai
factuellement vous regardez les chiffres
l'impact de la loi il est majeur et donc
il ne faut pas hésiter à légiférer pour
forcer
pour pousser et c'est ce qu'on fait
continuellement pour les comités
et pourquoi pas le monde de
l'intelligence artificielle on le fait
successivement toutes les majorités
quelles qu'elles soient vous avez parlé
de la loi copézimmermann on vient de
voter récemment une loi X1 qui continue
ce mouvement donc moi je crois qu'il ne
faut pas hésiter à légiférer en la
matière tant que nous n'avons pas
atteint l'objectif parce que si on
laisse faire la nature et bien on y
arrivera peut-être mais ça prendra 10
100 fois plus de temps donc nous n'avons
plus le temps donc je pense moi je crois
beaucoup en la législation l'index il
existe c'est important certains disent
n'est pas suffisamment contraignants moi
je crois quand même que c'est une
vitrine sur ce qu'est une entreprise et
je fais confiance à nos jeunes filles à
nos filles aux femmes d'une façon
générale pour quand elles ont la
possibilité de choisir entre deux
entreprises que elle privilégie
évidemment l'entreprise ou l'égalité
salariale est la plus forte et puis ça
permet aux entreprises d'avoir un regard
sur elle-même parfois elles n'ont pas
conscience c'est dingue elles n'ont pas
conscience de du niveau dans lequel
elles sont par rapport à l'égalité
homme-femme et l'index est un bon outil
pour qu'elle puisse s'évaluer et voir
dans quel domaine il faut qu'elle
produise des efforts mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut que
collectivement homme femme on se dit que
en fait une boîte qui ne pratique pas
une égalité salariale et qui n'a pas une
vraie volonté de le faire et
complètement ringarde et qu'elle n'est
pas désirable en fait ni pour le
consommateur finalement ni pour des
salariés ni pour des dirigeants surtout
à un moment où il y a une bataille de
l'emploi aujourd'hui puisque le taux de
chômage a baissé et donc il y a plutôt
les entreprises sont plutôt en train de
de recruter et d'essayer de recruter les
meilleurs profils et effectivement ça
peut être un élément d'attractivité
bueno la jolie cause là nous abordons la
délicate question des quotas alors moi
il y a 15 ans comme beaucoup de femmes
j'étais résolument contre les quotas
pensez en naïvement que la boussole de
l'égalité devrait fonctionner sur cette
fameuse phrase seule la compétence
compte bon on voit bien que cette
boussole ne fonctionne pas sinon il y
aurait des femmes en responsabilité
donc je suis désormais résolument pour
les quotas mais malheureusement notre
expérience vous avez raison évidemment
la loi elle est importante mais la loi
sauvadait qui était la seule loi
applicable à la loi X1 dans la fonction
publique on a fêté ses dix ans et on a
vu à quel point elle n'a pas été aussi
efficace qu'on l'aurait voulu et que les
quotas ont été finalement utilisés de
manière très restrictive on a demandé 20
puis 30 puis 40 jamais 50 pour que ça
nécessaire ne pas suffisant
soit décisive ce qui est décisif c'est
de faire appliquer la loi et ce que dit
le bilan du Sénat de la loi sauvadesse
c'est qu'en réalité les hommes ont
contourné les mécanismes de nomination
des femmes dans la haute fonction
publique au point vous le savez qu'un
certain nombre de ministères ont été
condamnés et ont préféré payer et je
dois le dire y compris le ministère de
la Justice avec 71% de talents féminins
dans ces rangs il a été condamné à deux
reprises pour ne pas avoir respecté les
quotas de nomination de femmes donc il
faut arrêter de dire que c'est de leur
faute et que elles sont prennent à il
faut les accompagner pour terminer je
voudrais vous faire commenter la
décision vous vous souvenez de la
première ministre elle a beaucoup tout
été commenté de la première ministre
néo-zélandaise madame Aldern qui a alors
c'est de la communication aussi mais il
y a des boulots c'est un décider et bien
d'interrompre son mandat en expliquant
que voilà elle avait besoin de passer à
autre chose et de s'occuper de sa vie
personnelle on revient un peu à la
question d'essentialisation ça fait du
bien aux femmes ça ou pas ah moi je
pense que oui ça fait du bien aux femmes
et aux hommes d'ailleurs c'est à dire
que en fait ça pose la question de la de
la force physique et de la et de la de
quels sont les critères qui font qu'on
ait un bon ou un mauvais Premier
ministre en l'occurrence elle n'a aucun
problème pour admettre qu'elle est à un
moment de sa vie où elle n'a plus
l'énergie plus la force etc donc moi je
trouve ça très très bien de l'assumer
ainsi j'avais une da haydern c'est son
nom on termine avec une image vous allez
nous nous la commenter il y a le bruit
de Pivet il s'agit de Madeleine Braun
j'ai découvert son son existence une
femme une résistante une antifasciste
une communiste alors c'est un homonyme
je crois
Madeleine Braun donc une plaque a été
inaugurée aujourd'hui pour pour le 8
mars tout à fait nous mettons des
plaques dans l'hémicycle là où on siégé
des grands parlementaires et Madeleine
Braun a été la première femme à présider
une séance à l'Assemblée nationale en
1946 c'est la première femme à être
montée au perchoir et par un hasard
incroyable de l'histoire c'est je n'ai
aucun lien de parenté avec elle et elle
porte le même nom que moi et je trouve
que c'est un clin d'oeil du destin 1945
et il y a la première cycle que quatre
plaques pour honorer des femmes
parlementaires là où il y en a 65 pour
les hommes et ben on s'arrête sur ce
chiffre là à méditer merci mesdames
c'était passionnant merci d'être venu
sur le plateau LCP pour pour cette
journée intern ationale du 8 mars vous
restez avec moi on va parler pure
politique retraite à présent Gaëlle
brune Pivet on va d'abord se pencher sur
le style Braun Pivet au perchoir une
voix des arbitrages elles aiment dans
Gava s'est plongée dans vos séances de
présidence de l'Assemblée regardez
présider une assemblée divisée fracturée
cette mission quasi impossible vous
l'avez voulu Yale brune pivée pour le
meilleur comme pour le pire bilan de 9
mois de président merci courageuse parce
que notre assemblée est plutôt
tumultueuse souriante mais ferme je ne
la sens pas partisane quand elle préside
les débats quand elle descend du
perchoir c'est autre chose dès vos
premières
ances à
l'ordre en proférant la phrase
aujourd'hui le lâche c'est vous on vous
adressant au ministre de l'économie et
des finances vous l'avez insulté je vous
inflige un rappel à l'ordre avec
inscription au procès-verbal donc je
prononce un rappel à l'ordre à votre
égard également je me vois contraintes
de prononcer un rappel à l'ordre parce
que vous avez utilisé à la tribune le
mot xénophobe à l'égard d'un parti
politique
vous avez également du gérer l'affaire
de Fournas indique une décoration
significative du climat
pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
chose rarissime vous suspendez la séance
des questions au Gouvernement flottement
pour certains prise de recul nécessaire
pour d'autres moi j'étais dans
l'hémicycle à ce moment-là on a eu quand
même un moment assez
intense et assez dur du débat
parlementaire on était dans un dans un
contexte je voyais pas comment on
pouvait continuer à mener des questions
du gouvernement je pense que la décision
a été bonne heureusement certains
moments sont l'occasion
de se mourir une de vos marques de
fabrique le scrutin éclore
alors j'ai un problème en face
et à gauche
quel tente de mettre du lien du lien en
permanence faut un peu décrispé
décrisper les débats je trouve que ça
c'est une ça me choque pas du tout
les retraites monsieur le ministre
est-ce que vous croyez que nous allons
passer 15 jours comme cela dans
l'hémicycle oui
c'est pas dans un amphi on n'est pas
dans une manip on est dans l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale
cette séquence va refroidir vos
relations avec la gauche je crois que
l'hémicycle vous demande des excuses
certains croient désolé chez vous un
conflit de loyauté être loyal à
l'institution au pouvoir législatif face
à l'Élysée
ou être macroniste bon et je pense que
voilà elle doit un peu osciller entre
les deux cela va pas être simple pour
elle mais là récemment je trouve que
dans la notamment dans le débat sur les
retraites elle est passée un peu trop du
côté défendre le macronisme alors madame
la Présidente peut-on être libre de
défendre l'assemblée tout en restant
loyal envers sa famille politique
répond si elle brune pipette c'est pas
un peu Mission Impossible libre et loyal
en même temps non ça me caractérise et
c'est comme ça je pense que je peux bien
présider cette institution moi j'ai
vraiment à cœur de faire en sorte d'être
la plus impartiale possible dans ma
gestion de cette maison dans ma gestion
des débats dans la relation que je peux
avoir avec les différents présidents de
groupe mais néanmoins je suis une femme
politique j'appartiens à une majorité je
sais pour quelle valeur je me suis
engagée et ces valeurs je les ai
chevillées au corps donc ça
comme une épreuve c'est complexe
évidemment sur des retraites des
insoumis qui vous qui vous traitent un
peu d'agents provocateur on a entendu
cette expression la présidente d'un camp
ça n'a pas été le cas et je crois que
tous les observateurs ont pu constater
que pendant ces débats des retraites
j'ai en président beaucoup permis à
l'Assemblée nationale de débattre
malheureusement pas jusqu'au bout mais
de de débattre pendant ces 15 jours
est-ce que vous désirez que ça n'est pas
facile ça n'est pas facile parce que la
situation aujourd'hui est complexe elle
est complexe politiquement on sent qu'il
y a beaucoup de tension tension dans
notre pays tensions dans l'hémicycle
justement quand les insoumis disent nous
on veut relayer cette colère dans le
pays dans l'hémicycle ils ont même
théorisé la théorie de la conflictualité
ils sont dans leur rôle en faisant ça
ils sont dans leur rôle mais il faut
qu'elle Assemblée nationale on se
souvienne toujours que le débat et doit
être organisé c'est un débat qui a des
règles qu'il y a une bien séance nous
avons un règlement nous avons nous
représentons les Français nous nous
appartenons plus totalement quand nous
sommes parlementaires cette fonction ce
mandat nous oblige et
à l'Assemblée nationale plus qu'ailleurs
dans cet enceinte là nous devons nous
respecter nous devons débattre nous
devons convaincre
convaincre les eaux que notre vision est
la bonne c'est vraiment ça la belle
politique les tensions elles viennent
pas forcément que des bancs de la gauche
et des insoumis les mauvaises manières
aussi on peut les voir dans votre camp
pas plus tard qu'hier soir avec ce
double bras d'honneur d'Éric
Dupont-Moretti pendant l'examen sur la
proposition de loi sur l'inégligibilité
des auteurs de violence conjugales alors
il s'est excusé mais la première
ministre la recadrer elle a bien fait de
le faire écoutez moi je suis venue voir
le ministre pour lui demander s'excuser
je me suis entretenue des irres avec la
première ministre à nouveau avec elle ce
matin à nouveau avec le ministre
également et je lui ai écrit un courrier
pour lui demander de rappeler aux
membres de sons gouvernement de
respecter l'institution que je préside
et de respecter les parlementaires vous
savez lorsque parfois et ce sont des
événements qui ont émaillé le débat
public nous avons
sanctionné des comportements de
parlementaires à l'égard de membres du
gouvernement nous attendons à tout le
mois que le gouvernement soit exemplaire
dans sa conduite dans son attitude dans
notre hémicycle et dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée vous avez pu voir les images
je sais que vous avez demandé
tout à fait j'ai visionné les images ce
midi je les ai visionnés en présence du
président Marleix pour que nous
puissions constater ensemble qu'elles
avaient été les gestes commis par le
garde donc et nous avons constaté
effectivement les gestes étaient
inappropriés et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai écrit à la première
ministre un courrier pour lui demander
de rappeler à l'ordre son gouvernement
voilà ces choses faites manifestement
puisque Elisabeth borne a expliqué ses
comportements n'avaient pas sa place
dans l'émission gros des aveux aussi
pour la majorité puisque cette
proposition de loi qui était portée par
Aurore Berger a été rejeté hier soir
dans l'hémicycle proposition de loi qui
a été née de la faire Catena ce qui
visait donc à rendre inéligible les élus
condamnés pour violence conjugales
textes opportuniste pour l'opposition
Aurore berger n'a pas apprécié mais
pourtant une partie de la majorité n'a
pas souhaité voter ce texte est-ce qu'il
était bien ficelé est-ce que franchement
un texte un peu anticapnase c'est ce
qu'on entend dans l'opposition c'était
opportun c'est un sujet qui est très
compliqué c'est le sujet de
l'exemplarité des élus et moi je me
souviens en 2017 nous souhaitions le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron avait mis dans son programme le
fait que pour être élu de la République
il fallait avoir un casier judiciaire
vierge nous avons légiféré en 2017 dans
les lois confiance et cette proposition
c'est heurté à une difficulté
constitutionnelle et nous avons fait une
liste d'infractions qui ne doivent pas
figurer sur le casier judiciaire nous
avions prévu les cas de violence
conjugales la présidente Berger a voulu
aller plus loin rendant cette peine
obligatoire alors que dans ce que nous
avions prévu de gravité facultatif donc
elle a voulu aller un cran
supplémentaire
vous savez ce qui est important c'est
que ça va toujours dans la même
direction c'est-à-dire une exemplarité
accrue des élus je crois que ça
correspond à une attente de nos
concitoyens ils attendent ça de nous et
donc vous voyez si nous avions pu le
faire nous aurions dit casier judiciaire
vierge alors on est entré dans une phase
décisive de la réforme des retraites au
lendemain d'une journée d'action très
suivie d'abord est-ce que vous êtes
confiante et là je m'adresse à la
députée Renaissance est-ce que ça va
passer est-ce que cette réforme va être
votée
je le souhaite mais vous êtes confiant
s'il y a une majorité à l'Assemblée vous
pensez je le pense je le pense parce que
alors on va voir maintenant quel est le
texte qui est issu des débats du Sénat
quel est le texte qui sera peut-être
issu d'une commission mixte paritaire
pour le moment nous sommes encore dans
une série d'hypothèse les débats
parlementaires se tiennent encore ça
dépend prochain vous savez les députés
sont des gens qui votent de façon
éclairée donc je ne peux pas vous
certifier
une majorité à l'assemblée que les
députés voteront en majorité un texte
dont je ne connais pas la teneur c'est
quand même difficile donc mais je pense
que nous avons une majorité à
l'Assemblée pour considérer qu'il faut
faire une réforme des retraites et que
la réforme qui est proposée aujourd'hui
par le gouvernement et celle qui
correspond aux besoins financiers de
notre système tout en étant celle qui
permet de réparer un certain nombre
d'injustices est-ce que le gouvernement
doit aller jusqu'au bout si c'est pour
passer par le 49-3 ou les ordonnances où
ce serait l'ouverture d'une forme de
crise politique dans ce cas là je crois
que il ne faut pas mettre la charrue
avant les boeufs le gouvernement a des
outils qui lui permettront d'agir le cas
échéant aujourd'hui moi je compte sur le
débat parlementaire je compte sur le
Sénat j'ai d'excellentes relations avec
le président Larcher dont je sais qu'il
souhaite aller jusqu'au bout de l'examen
de ce texte et donc moi je crois que ça
c'est quelque chose d'important parce
que vous voyez on a eu un sentiment de
frustration à l'Assemblée nationale avec
un débat qui n'a pas pu aller jusqu'à
son terme mais qui ne nous a pas permis
de débattre de la pénibilité pas
suffisamment des carrières longues et
pas des suffisamment des femmes et c'est
le Sénat justement les républicains qui
met sur la table une proposition avec la
possibilité soit de choisir une surcote
à 64,35% soit pour les femmes de partir
à 63 bonne idée le gouvernement ne l'a
pas eu mais le Parlement mais le
Parlement fort heureusement et force de
proposition et à de bonnes idées
mais moi je crois que on a un système
malheureusement de retraite qui ne fait
que reproduire et corriger des
inégalités professionnelles d'une vie et
on sait aujourd'hui que les femmes sont
plus souvent victimes de temps partiel
choisi sont plus souvent victimes de
carrière hachées sont plus souvent
celles qui s'arrêtent soit pour élever
des enfants soit pour s'occuper d'un
enfant handicapé sur les inégalités en
amont de leurs parents femmes qu'il faut
régler ce sont les inégalités en amont
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure qu'ils
font impérativement régler le système de
retraite peut corriger peut améliorer
mais il ne peut pas effacer d'un trade
plume 40 ans d'inégalités
professionnelles entre dans une carrière
d'une femme et une carrière d'un homme
un tout petit mot sur Gisèle Halimi que
le Président de la République a célébré
aujourd'hui le fils de Gisèle Halimi
n'ira pas
le palais de justice il l'a fait savoir
parce qu'il y a eu trop de polémiques il
estime que le président fait diversion
en plein bras de fer sur les retraites
c'est dommage oui je trouve ça dommage
parce que aujourd'hui on en a les femmes
on honore des femmes courageuses des
femmes de conviction des combattants sa
mère en était une et je trouve que
aujourd'hui peut-être que gisais leur
limite aurait été avec nous ce matin à
l'hôtel de lacet où nous avons reçu des
femmes iraniennes des femmes afghane qui
se battent pour avoir le droit à
l'instruction le droit de ne pas être
marié de force le droit à l'avortement
et je pense que Gisèle Halimi aurait été
de tous ses combats là c'est vrai
qu'elle a semblé vous avez organisé un
grand coloc avec le choix de mettre en
avant des des femmes on le voit à
l'assemblée des femmes combattantes pour
la liberté afghane iranienne guinéenne
ou encore femme irakienne yesidi on est
tout petit à côté d'elle il y a 8 mars
en France pour vous le premier des
combats dans le monde pour les femmes
c'est lequel
c'est le combat de l'égalité
on a parlé du droit à l'instruction moi
je crois que les femmes ont besoin ou
qu'elles soient de pouvoir
s'épanouir de pouvoir apprendre de
pouvoir exercer les métiers qu'elle
souhaite parce que c'est elle qui après
aussi élèveront leur petite fille on a
eu une jeune femme tout à l'heure qui
nous parlait de sa mère qui était
probablement restée
ignorante soumise et en fait elle elle a
pu accéder à l'instruction et qui lui a
permis aussi de s'émanciper donc le
droit à l'instruction à l'égalité sont
des beaux combats et que nous devons
accompagner nous devons être à côté
toutes ces femmes vous restez avec moi
c'est la dernière partie de l'émission
qu'on va ouvrir tout de suite avec nos
affranchis on les accueille tout de
suite leur parti pris pour vous faire
réagir allez on vous accueille tous les
deux maître Bertrand Perrier on va
terminer avec vous tiens hein ce sera la
petite surprise du chef la carte blanche
de Bertrand Perrier et une Sabatier œil
sur le numérique on en parlait tout à
l'heure où sont les femmes dans
l'intelligence artificielle dans le
numérique il y a une application dont
vous allez nous parler ce soir c'est
TikTok on en parle beaucoup à
l'Assemblée le Congrès américain
réfléchit même à l'interdire absolument
ça c'est la dernière actualité bonjour
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale vous n'êtes pas officiellement
présente sur ce réseau social chinois
Tik Tok vous n'avez pas de compte mais
alors on voit beaucoup de plus en plus
j'ai envie de dire de vidéos avec vous
ce qui marche le mieux sont les
invictives les suspensions de séances
quand vous rappelez à l'ordre aussi une
ou un députée d'ailleurs d'après vous
combien font de vue les vidéos avec le
hashtag il y a elle Brown je ne sais pas
beaucoup 4,4 millions quand même je ne
savais même pas que le hashtag existait
en fait alors bon quand même pour
relativiser parce que le hashtag Macron
c'est 4,5 milliards
de la République et puis en plus lui il
a son propre compte qu'il anime
d'ailleurs avec une certaine assiduité
comme on peut voir avec ces petites
vidéos
c'est Guillaume TC sur Twitter qui écrit
avons-nous tout fait pour que notre
maison ne brûle plus autant voilà en
plus la photo qui met avec donc je ne
suis pas sûr que honnêtement les nattes
de Greta maïs super bien mais je crois
qu'on prend l'idée qu'il y a derrière
voilà donc assiduité une certaine
aisance mais ça n'empêche pas quand même
notre président de la République de
critiquer vertement ce réseau social Tik
Tok il parle d'un problème de qui crée
une vraie addiction chez les jeunes de
la propagande russe cachée aussi ce sont
des accusations qui ont été portées
comme en premier aux États-Unis il faut
le rappeler là-bas les politiques nous
partent carrément d'un cheval de Troie
du Parti communiste chinois utilisé pour
surveiller les Américains une menace
pour la sécurité nationale le pouvoir
même de retourner le cerveau des ados
avec ses algorithmes de recommandation
qui sont assez obscures alors il y a des
questions de sécurité qui se posent aux
Etats-Unis on prend le problème à bras
le corps et nous en France on a
effectivement la dernière actualité hier
encore le conseiller de sécurité
nationale de la Maison Blanche qui
défendait un texte qui va permettre sans
doute d'interdire les applications de
manière générale étrangère qui peuvent
avoir une menace sur la sécurité
intérieure parce qu'elle collecte
énormément de données ce bannissement on
le retrouve de plus en plus proche de
nous en les institutions européennes
décidé que leur fonctionnaire n'avait
plus droit d'utiliser Tik Tok sur les
smartphones et puis en France pour
l'instant je dirais on étudie le dossier
il y a le président de la commission de
la défense qui s'est retiré Thomas mais
pour l'instant pas de vous allez réagir
mais pas de décision institutionnelle
voilà alors bon je sais pas si on est un
peu trop prudent en tout cas ici on se
trouve clairement au milieu d'une guerre
géopolitique sino-américaine mais ça
doit pas occulter les vrais
problématiques qui sont derrière dans
son monde numérique quand on parle de
soupçons d'espionnage de chiffonnage
d'information personnelle de dérive
violente de dépendance de manipulation
étatique c'est intéressant de voir que
les États-Unis réagissent très fort
parce qu'en fait ils ont conscience de
la puissance de ces plateformes
numériques de ce que ça permet d'accéder
à ces données cette éminemment politique
et stratégique question donc à la
présidente de l'Assemblée aujourd'hui
nous moi j'aimerais qu'on se pose les
mêmes questions mais vis-à-vis des
applications numériques de manière
générale ce sont des puissances
étrangères pas uniquement chinoises
aussi américaine et je voulais vous
poser la question vous interpeller sur
ce sujet
décider au sein de l'Assemblée nationale
on parle de mise en garde des députés
est-ce que ça pourrait aller jusqu'à
être une interdiction d'utiliser
l'application TikTok alors
l'interdiction à des parlementaires non
c'est à mon sens quelque chose qui n'est
pas souhaitable en revanche nous avons
des des formations des en fait des
appels à la vigilance qui sont
finalement qui vont au delà de Tik Tok
qui vont aussi sur la sécurité
informatique nous savons que nous sommes
des cibles pour les puissances
étrangères et il faut que les
parlementaires et bien conscience de
l'environnement dans lequel ils évoluent
donc il y a cet environnement dont vous
parlez Tik Tok réseaux sociaux etc mais
pas seulement et il faut que la prise de
conscience elle soit globale pour que
prise de conscience
à culturelle
on enchaîne parce que je voudrais quand
même vous laisser un peu de temps carte
blanche ce soir manifestement vous êtes
assez inspirés
on va voir madame la Présidente cheriel
Brown privé si vous le voulez bien
pendant les 3 minutes qui viennent je ne
vais pas être avocat vous n'allez pas
être député pardon je ne vais pas être
chroniqueur vous n'allez pas être député
on va tous les deux être avocat je le
suis toujours vous ne l'êtes plus d'où
ma question pourquoi pourquoi ce choix
pourquoi le perchoir plutôt que les
prétoirs plus quoi le tailleur plutôt
que la robe et pourquoi les incidents de
séances plutôt que les incidents
d'audience car j'en suis certain quand
vous vous sentez un peu seul là-haut sur
votre estrade il vous arrive de vous
souvenir de ce 25 janvier 1996 où vous
êtes approchés timidement de la cour
d'appel de Paris pour dire je le jure il
vous arrive aussi de vous souvenir de
votre petit bureau 156 rue de Rivoli et
de la figure tutélaire d'Hervé thémime
et je veux croire que malgré les dorures
les honneurs et les tambours de la Garde
Républicaine vous avez gardé en vous
cette petite flamme de la défense qui
avait fait de vous une pénaliste parce
que vous le savez être pénaliste c'est
pas métier c'est une vocation et elle ne
vous abandonne jamais vraiment et si
vous avez pour le moment choisi d'écrire
la loi je suis sûr qu'un jour vous aurez
envie de revenir parmi nous pour la
faire respecter vous y retrouverez alors
vos concerts désormais majoritaires dans
la profession très largement et qui sont
les héritières de Gisèle alibi que nous
fêtons aujourd'hui et qui chaque jour
met à mal le cliché du ténor à la voix
rau qui est à l'éloquence testostérone
et qui fait vibrer les cours d'assises
car le combat des femmes passe aussi par
le droit et par ses vigies que sont les
avocats et les juges pour que recule les
discriminations les violences les abus
le harcèlement les insultes dans les
foyers dans les entreprises dans
l'espace public sur Internet et aussi on
oublie parfois dans les prisons en
France bien sûr mais aussi ailleurs en
Iran en Turquie en Russie vous voyez
proclamer abstraitement des droits c'est
bien mais les mettre en oeuvre au
quotidien c'est peut-être encore mieux
alors voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
aujourd'hui madame la Présidente chers
j'ai fait vérifier lorsque vous avez
quitté le barreau de Paris le 18
septembre de 1999 vous étiez à jour de
vos cotisations ordinaires rien ne
s'oppose donc à votre retour et je vous
le dis nous vous attendons vous ferez
alors comme nous vous pesterez contre
les lois trop nombreuses mal écrites
inapplicables ce seront les vôtres vous
râlerez sur la lenteur d'une justice
sans moyens de ce sont ceux que vous lui
aurez donné et le soir vous sortirez du
Palais de Justice fourbu sans doute mais
heureuse et vous vous direz alors ce
n'est donc pas un hasard si le mot
plaidoirie est un mot féminin
une réaction très brève ça vous manque
ou pas vous pourriez y revenir au
barreau ça ça me manque pas parce que
j'aime follement la politique mais
j'y pense avec beaucoup d'émotion et je
me revois ce jour où j'ai prêté serment
à la cour d'appel de Paris ou quand je
vais aux audiences solennelles de la
Cour de cassation quand je vais dans un
palais de justice et je me vois
effectivement j'ai souvenir de moi
cheminant entre le palais et le 156 rue
de Rivoli avec ma robe sous le bras
justement la défense et j'aimais porter
ses convictions et être la voix de ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas comme disait souvent
pierre-hick qui vient de nous quitter et
ouais j'ai folle moi aimer cette
profession aussi merci beaucoup on va
s'arrêter là je suis sûr que vous aurez
des choses à vous dire on est en retard
désolé restez avec nous sur la Chaîne
Parlementaire très bien de soirée et à
demain merci à vous merci beaucoup
[Musique]